my parents immigrated from india 40
years ago
to southwest ohio where i was born they
weren't rich
i asked my dad why i chose to come to
ohio and he said it's because his older
sister who also came from india
lived in fort wayne indiana now that of
course begged the question of
why my aunt had left india all the way
to come to fort wayne
and we joke around that because it's the
only state where the word india
is actually contained in the name of the
state indiana so that's the story we
tell anyway
my dad was a company man himself he was
in at ge's evendale ohio plant he worked
there loyally for over 40 years
and my mom was a geriatric psychiatrist
who spent most of her career treating
patients with alzheimer's disease
in nursing homes in the ohio area if i
learned one thing during my own
upbringing
it was the being the odd man out in a
crowd isn't always a bad thing
i went to a pretty rough public school
through eighth grade where it wasn't
particularly abnormal for a kid to show
up to school with a knife
my parents then switched me to a private
jesuit high school something that
actually
shaped my own views even though i'm a
hindu and when i went to college and i
graduated from harvard in 2007 in
biology
i ended up becoming a biotech investor
rather than an academic scientist
i went to law school along the way i
went to yale i had an itch to study law
and political philosophy
but i decided to keep my job at the fund
where i worked and after i finished law
school in 2013
i had a new itch i had an itch to build
something rather than just be a passive
investor in biotech
so i left my job to start a biotech
company i started by developing a drug
for alzheimer's disease
a passion that i'd actually picked up
for my mother but ultimately that drug
failed it was the first drug we
developed
that failure hurt and it chased me
but it also taught me that hardship
isn't the same thing as victimhood
and eventually the company thankfully
went on to develop important medicines
for other diseases that helped a lot of
patients in the end one of which was a
drug for prostate cancer
i led the company for seven years until
i stepped down as ceo this january
because i felt even more compelled to
help treat a different kind of cancer
it's one that affects the heart of our
country it's not a biological cancer
it's a cultural one and given the
reality of the world that we live in
i wasn't really free to speak about it
as the ceo of a high profile company
so i had to step down so that i could
talk about it not as a ceo
but as a citizen that new disease
that new infection is spreading across
our country like
wildfire it is one that even the best of
science is not going to cure
and that new disease is called woke
culture it's the new secular religion in
america
and its belief system centers on the
idea that your identity is based on your
race
your gender and your sexual orientation
full stop
it posits that america is a systemically
racist country
and that if you're black you're
inherently disadvantaged and that if
you're white you're inherently
privileged
no matter how much money you have no
matter what your upbringing was
your race and gender govern who you are
and what thoughts you're allowed to have
that's it
congresswoman ianna presley summed it up
pretty neatly last year actually when
she unapologetically declared
we don't need any more black faces that
don't want to be a black voice
we don't need any more brown faces that
don't want to be a brown voice end quote
i'm going to guess that i don't fit her
description of what counts as a brown
voice
here's the clever part about how this
particular virus spreads
if you disagree with any of those claims
then that actually means you're just
racist and you don't know it
and the more you resist awoke claim the
more that's seen to validate it
if you say i'm not racist that means
you are racist if you say all lives
matter
that somehow means that you believe that
black lives don't matter
if you capitalize the w in white or fail
to capitalize the b
in black you're racist and there is no
greater damnation
in modern america than to be labeled a
racist so between pledging fealty to
this new religion
and being tarred with the scarlet r
everyday americans are choosing to bend
the knee
the consequences may be existential for
america this has created
a new culture of fear in our country
fear of losing your job
fear of failing a class at school fear
of becoming a pariah in your own
community and almost every day somebody
new
is sacrificed at the altar and
excommunicated from civil society
for saying the wrong thing this new
culture of fear has completely eroded
our culture of free speech in america a
good measure of the health of any
democracy especially american democracy
is the percentage of people who actually
feel free to say what they actually
think
in public and right now i am sorry to
say that we are doing abysmally on that
metric
according to a recent survey conducted
by the cato institute over 60 percent of
americans
uh overwhelming majority of this country
says they are afraid of saying what they
believe
because of the current political climate
that is not america
it is not the country that my my parents
came halfway across
the world to join it is not the country
i learned to pledge allegiance to
as a kid we have a new red guard in our
country
that's reminiscent of the chinese
cultural revolution except instead of
adhering to marxism the new guiding
principle for today's red guard
is this new form of wokism
so that's where we are today in the name
of diversity we've sacrificed true
diversity of thought
in the name of democracy we've
sacrificed our most important democratic
norms
of free speech and open debate in the
name of inclusion
we've created an exclusionary culture
where certain views are just not welcome
so how did we get here how did this new
wokism become so dominant in our country
the story goes back to the 1990s a new
discipline emerged in american academia
it was called critical race theory it
posited that race and other inherited
characteristics
created these invisible power structures
that actually govern our real social
relationships
in the 1890s karl marx had posited that
the invisible power relationships were
based on economic disempowerment but
critical race theory changed that
narrative
by the 1990s critical race theory
posited that the real culprit
was invisible racial disempowerment
that's when locaism was born
now to be clear in the 90s wokism used
to be about challenging the system
and there's something about that which i
respect even if i disagree with it
but today woke-ism is not about
challenging the system wokism
is the system so how did this fringe
intellectual theory from unknown
academics in the 1990s
managed to infect our most important
social institutions today that is the
question
and in my opinion the answer actually
begins with the 2008 financial crisis
immediately after the 08 crisis you'll
remember corporations were the bad guys
the old left used to say that corporate
power was bad and the thing we needed to
do
was redistribute money from rich people
to poor people to help poor people
agree or not that was their theory but
the new modern
woke left in the post 2008 world had a
different theory
they said that the real problem wasn't
poverty it wasn't economic injustice
rather it was racial injustice and
misogyny
and bigotry i guess what that presented
a once in a generation opportunity
for wall street they could no longer be
the bad guys but instead
could actually become the good guys just
by adopting these woke values
now remember occupy wall street that was
after 2008 that was a tough pill for
wall street to swallow but this woke-ism
stuff
that was easy applaud diversity and
inclusion put some women on boards
create an affinity group for analysts of
color you're good to go
just look at what goldman sachs did last
year when its ceo declared from of
course the mountaintops of davos
that goldman would not take a company
public in the united states
unless it met goldman sachs's standards
for board diversity where of course
goldman's the sole arbiter of who counts
as diverse
the banks were thrilled to dance to this
new woke tune
they were happy to lend both their money
and their legitimacy and their
credibility to this new woke movement
but they only need one thing in return
just one ask in return
woke left get the new left to leave wall
street alone
and it worked each side won from the
trade
big banks got to use their market power
to force these woke values down our
throats
and in return the new left agrees to
look the other way when it comes to
leaving their market power intact so in
a nutshell here's how it worked
wall street got in bed with a bunch of
woke millennials together
they both woke capitalism and of course
they put occupy wall street
up for adoption you don't even know what
that is anymore that's the wall street
edition
as it turns out there's a really similar
backroom deal playing out in the other
coast in silicon valley as well and
here's the way it works over there
woke activists demand that big tech
censors political views that they don't
like
and in return the left agrees to leave
big tech's monopoly power intact
and again it is working masterfully
for both sides that is how this new
arranged marriage works
this is not a marriage of love this is
more like mutual prostitution
and it is working and the net result is
the rise of america's newest leviathan
the woke industrial complex it is no
longer just wall street
it is no longer just silicon valley it
is the entirety of corporate america as
we know it
it's coca-cola training its employees on
quote-unquote how to be less white
and issuing public statements about
voting laws that make it sound more like
a super pac
than a soft drink manufacturer it's
united airlines saying that it's going
to apply a quota system
based on race and gender to the pilots
who are in the cockpit
even if that means throwing out pilot
tests as a part of the process
it's major league baseball deciding to
move this year's all-star game
out of atlanta it is nike donating tens
of millions of dollars
to black lives matter a marxist movement
that professes to care about black lives
or while it also calls for the
decimation of the nuclear family
structure while by the way nike of
course continues to market 200
sneakers to black kids in the inner city
who can't afford to buy books for school
go figure
liberals accept it because they love
work causes old school republicans
look the other way because their inner
conscience tells them
that the free market can do no wrong
without realizing that the so-called
free market that they idealize
doesn't actually exist today so both
sides are ultimately blinded to the rise
of this new 21st century
monster that is far more insidious and
far more powerful than anything we have
seen in the history of our country
now i would love to tell you that it
doesn't get any worse than that but it
does
it does get worse there's a new guest
who's shown up on the scene
and turned this unholy alliance into a
threesome that's the communist party of
china
they understand this game more deeply
than any of us there is even a chinese
word
for wokeness byzuo is the word
it literally refers to woke white people
in the united states
and they use it to laugh at us and even
worse they're using wokism as a
geopolitical tool
to erode our standing on the global
stage and if you have any doubt about
that
just look at what they're saying last
year
when european union leaders pressed xi
jinping about china's human rights
violations
including locking up over 1 million
uyghurs
in concentration camps who by the way
apple uses a slave labor to make their
iphones i bet they don't tell you that
his first response was that black lives
matter shows the united states
is no better last month
when china's top diplomat came right
here to the alaska summit
in his opening remarks he falsely
asserts
that the united states is slaughtering
that is his word
slaughtering black americans and that he
hopes the united states does better on
human rights
that would be laughable if it didn't
have such serious consequences
they know that our greatest geopolitical
advantage is not our nuclear arsenal
it is our moral standing
but now they're using american
capitalism as a weapon to accomplish
their own goals by using woke
corporations to undermine the united
states
from within take disney just a couple of
years ago
said it couldn't film in georgia in the
state of georgia
if they passed a new anti-abortion
statute
yet they just filmed mulan last year in
the xinjiang province of china
which is literally ground zero the
epicenter of the uyghur human rights
crisis
and they didn't just film there they
went further they said we
thank the local government they thanked
the ccp
for allowing them to film there that's
disney
the nba it's even worse the nba
regularly
regularly decries alleged racial
injustice here in the united states
yet it does not say a peep as they
continue to expand into the chinese
market it gets worse than that
when daryl mori the general manager of
the houston rockets once tweeted
fight for freedom stand with hong kong
lebron james one of the most outspoken
critics of the last president
one of the most outspoken supporters of
black lives matter just last week
tweeting a picture of a cop in columbus
ohio and saying hold him accountable
he's the guy who immediately came of
course to china's
public defense this two-faced behavior
of corporations and their celebrities
celebrity cronies is not just an
accident
it is by design the ccp is playing us
like a chinese mandolin and it's working
and they're doing it by using our own
companies against us and why are these
companies doing it
the answer is plain and simple money
china restricts market access to any
company
who criticizes the ccp and even better
than that
it favors market access to china for
companies who criticize the united
states it is as simple as that
companies are simply doing what
companies do whatever allows them
to make the most money unfortunately the
american people are falling for it
it's worked like a charm especially for
china so it is now no surprise that they
are using
that same tactic to deflect
accountability for coven 19 as well in
particular the origin of this virus
let's just talk about the name of the
virus
the marburg virus is named after a town
in germany where that virus originated
the ebola virus is named after a river
in africa where it came from the zika
virus is named after forest in africa
where it came from
countless other examples japanese
encephalus encephalitis virus i could go
on
even when it comes to covet 19 you can
say the uk strain
you can say the south african strain you
can say the brazilian strain
you can say the indian double mutant
strain any of those
are perfectly acceptable but if you say
the wuhan virus you are immediately
bashed as a racist
and a bigot ask yourself why the ccp has
successfully weaponized not just the
coven 19 pandemic
but the woke pandemic by using the
threat of racism against the united
states to evade accountability
for its own actions and worst of all
american corporations
are helping them at every step of the
way that is the real chinese virus that
we need to fight
it is a cultural virus that erodes
america's greatest competitive advantage
by equating american idealism with
chinese nihilism and when that happens
nihilism wins every time thank you
lebron james
corporations win woke activists win the
chinese communist party wins
the real losers of this game are the
american people and american democracy
itself so what's the solution to all of
this
in 1980 one of my heroes ronald reagan
correctly identified that the greatest
threat to individual liberty and
prosperity in this country
was big government but today that's only
half the story
the real threat in america isn't just
big government
it is this new hybrid of big government
and big business
look i am all for cutting taxes and
slashing government regulations
but as abraham lincoln a great
republican said 160 years ago
the dogmas of a quiet past are
inadequate
to the stormy present we are going to
need
new legislative solutions ones that meet
the challenges of 2021
not just the challenges of 1980. this is
no longer about just saving capitalism
from big government this is about saving
capitalism
from itself in the short run we're going
to need legislative solutions
that stay true to our unabiding belief
in the power of private enterprise yes
but while also recognizing the ways in
which our system of private enterprise
has been co-opted and corrupted by
external forces
take the case of big tech censorship
conventional wisdom holds that
technology companies should be free to
regulate what content
does and does not show up on their
websites because of private companies
and the first amendment conventionally
only protects against big government
censorship
fine but that actually misses the
essence of what's happening in the real
world today
the liberal wing of congress has
actually co-opted silicon valley
through the back door to do what
government cannot directly accomplish
under the constitution if you have any
doubt about that look at what they do in
these congressional hearings
democrats regularly threaten social
media companies with regulatory reprisal
if they fail to take down so-called hate
speech or misinformation
and it works last year the day before
yet another democratic congressional
grilling
facebook announces new restrictions on
so-called
hate speech and these restrictions
became even more stringent after of
course
democrats took control of the white
house and the senate
in addition to the house of
representatives it was actually what
connecticut senator
richard blumenthal attributed to in his
words quote unquote a shift
in the political winds those are his
words and he was right
now if those congressional threats are
the stick
there's also the legislative carrot
that's section 230
of the 1996 communications decency act
which immunizes tech companies from
liability for censoring otherwise
constitutionally protected speech so
taken together
these actually represent a modern form
of crony capitalism
except in reverse big government is
actually able to turn
companies into pawns to engage in
otherwise constitutionally prohibited
censorship
and personally i believe that state
action under the mantle of private
enterprise
is still state action i believe we have
to a statutory fix for section 230 we
need to fix section 230 and it says that
if you benefit from this kind of broad
federal immunity
then these tech companies also have to
be bound by the same standards
as federal government plain and simple
federal government cannot dispatch a
private company to do what the federal
government
can't do directly and when that comes to
political censorship it means abiding by
the standards of the first amendment
after all
even if you are a tech company so long
as you benefit from section 230 immunity
i'm in favor of other legislative fixes
that eliminate crony capitalism
and especially this reverse form of
crony capitalism
and the fundamental unfairness that
results from it especially fundamental
in
unfairness arising from flawed policies
in the first place let me give you
another example
if we live in a world today where
private businesses
cannot discriminate on the basis of race
sex
or religious belief then i do not
believe those businesses
should be able to discriminate on the
basis of political belief
either yet that is exactly what's
happening day in and day out in our
country today
we could easily solve that problem in a
really simple way
add political belief to the list of
protected classes
in title vii of the civil rights act of
1964
full stop now of course there's the
libertarian side of my brain even the
libertarian side of my conscience
which says that look isn't it wrong to
add just another rule to what private
businesses can and can't do
because in a libertarian utopia the
market should solve these problems on
its own
i'll tell you how the market could solve
the problem for example i used to think
this way myself
if some business is discriminated
against conservatives then that should
in theory
create a business opportunity for
somebody else to capitalize on for
example by hiring those same
conservatives
who are fired by these businesses over
here well guess what that creates a
market opportunity for the next guy
who can just hire those fired
conservatives sounds
sounds great on its face if you're in
libertarian utopia
here's the main problem with that
argument
that same logic should apply to
discrimination based on race
sex or religion too yet
as a society we now unquestioningly
accept
those restraints on businesses now
perhaps there's an academic debate
debate to be had
somewhere about whether even those
restrictions
were or are a bad idea too but that is
truly a moot point today
since nobody not a republican not a
democrat
not even any public libertarians are
seriously advocating for the idea
that businesses should be able to
discriminate based on race or sex
or religion so my view is this against
that backdrop
if a business can't fire someone because
they're black
or muslim or gay
then a business should not be able to
fire someone just because they're an
outspoken conservative either if a
social media
can't kick you off their platform for
being black
or muslim or gay then they should not be
able to deny you service
just because you're a hard-line
republican or a democrat for that matter
either
this is not just an academic debate it
is happening almost
every day in this country if it can
happen to the 45th president of the
united states
it can happen to anybody i go through a
handful of additional legal solutions
in my upcoming book but in reality
these legal solutions are just a form of
symptomatic therapy
what we really need in this country is a
cultural
cure the real solution to these problems
is actually to gradually rebuild a
shared vision of american identity that
is so deep
and so powerful that it dilutes this
wokest nonsense
to irrelevance the answer does not
actually begin with the government
it begins with everyday citizens who are
willing to speak up
and challenge the new woke dogma at
school
at work at home and in their community
it also means cultivating a shared
identity both in ourselves
and in the next generation of americans
with the revival of civic education that
we have long missed in this country
our schools teach our kids to view our
history with shame rather than pride
patriotism is on the decline religion
has nearly disappeared
what does it even mean to be an american
today in the year 2021
i cannot remember a time in my life
where we more badly needed an answer to
that question
and i personally believe that answering
that question is the hardest
and most important work we will ever do
as americans
today as a people we are hungry for a
cause we are hungry for a sense of
purpose we are hungry
for identity the absence of a shared
cause in america is the black hole
at the center of our nation's soul and
when you have a vacuum that runs that
deep
bad things start to fill the void that
is part of what makes wokeness
so appealing as the new religion of our
time it is the modern version
of opioid for our masses as americans
our jobs in the coming years
is to fill that void with something more
meaningful
than just wokeness americans are hungry
for a cause
and yet we have forgotten that in
america our country itself
can be that cause we have spent over a
decade
celebrating our diversity and our
differences
that we have forgotten all of the ways
in which we're actually the same
united by a common set of ideals as a
country
most nations throughout human history
were defined on the basis of an
ethnicity
or a language or religion or a monarch
not america
we were the first and greatest country
to find on the basis of a set of ideals
that unified a polyglot divided group of
people
america was not just a place it was a
shared vision of what that place could
be
and a fundamental part of that vision
was the american dream
the idea that no matter who your parents
were you can achieve your dreams with
hard work
your own commitment and your own
ingenuity i have lived that dream
we call it the american dream for a
reason it is not a destination that we
reach
it is a vision that we aspire to one
that we will always fall short of
but continue to keep pursuing anyway
that is part of what it means
to have a dream but over the last decade
something scary happened
we woke up and once you wake up from a
dream you forget what it was all about
you might remember how it felt
and pretty soon you forget that too
that's the real danger of wokeness
but we still have time to get it right
if the 2010s were about celebrating our
demographic diversity
then the 2020s should be about
celebrating what binds us together
as a people the american dream e
pluribus unum
from many one the other side might say
this is just a load of high-minded
drivel
because we never lived up to our ideals
as a country and you know what
they have a point it's true that america
isn't perfect
we weren't perfect at our founding we
aren't perfect today
i will venture to say we never will be
perfect as a country but more than any
nation
in human history america is the pursuit
of perfection
the pursuit of a more perfect union the
pursuit of happiness
the pursuit of liberty equality and
justice for all
these are the values that won the
american revolution these are the values
that reunited us
after the civil war these are the values
that won us world war one
and world war ii and the cold war these
are the values that still give hope to
the free world and if we embrace
these common values then nobody in the
world not a corporation
not a nation not a virus is going to
feed us that is what true american
exceptionalism
is all about and that is what we will
need to marshal in order to defeat this
new cultural epidemic
thank you
you